[Music]
hello everyone and so we were already
introduced but just to make sure this is
Magda and I'm Yannick and we are data
scientists at Krupa Pratt's we where we
are part of the Big Data team and for
those of you who don't know group of
ratatouille is comprises several
companies that all provide products and
services in the HR space particularly
recruiting most of my and Magnus team's
work is around proxy Bell which is the
largest job board in Poland but before
we actually start some of you might ask
I'm a data scientist why would I even
care about this edge I've stuff I'm not
a product developer or agile coach and I
guess that's fair but before I proceed I
would nevertheless provide three reasons
why I think you should take this
seriously so first of all you might not
be a product owner right now but you
well might be in the future so obviously
you've heard one thousand times how
machine learning is taking over and so
on and there will be need of people who
will manage those projects and data
savvy people at that so you might well
find yourself filling that role some
time even if you do plan to stay a data
scientist forever it might be still
useful to actually learn how to
communicate with product owners to learn
how they think and what are their
concerns so that you can firstly
cooperate better but secondly be able to
actually propose your own solutions and
especially in large organizations that
will go a long way of
establishing credibility of your team
and lastly even if you want to be a data
scientist forever and the I don't know
you live in a basement and you're
only data science product is a cat food
recommender for your lovely mittens well
I guess we still provide some useful
advice to make that cat food the best
cat food then that he will get ever
because he's worth it so what do we
actually do in practice so as I said
most of our work is around the Pratt
repeal website so obviously we have
recommender systems we have a search
engine we do anomaly detection but on
top of that we try to analyze and
predict user behavior we forecast sales
and we create decision support systems
so I guess there is no lack of
interesting problems and we thought it
might be fun to present our agile
approach on a concrete case that we do
at our work so this is what price repel
looks like some of you might have seen
it actually and there are like few
things on every offer there is a job
title that implies a category so for
example every programmer job offer will
be in the programming category and this
one is actually from Warsaw and it has a
content as well so to provide some
business background for for this problem
on propel the the way that we do
business is that recruiters or companies
post the job offers on the website and
we try to make sure that I get as many
skilled applicants as possible right so
obviously just just hearing that it's
kind of no surprise that knowing how
many clicks there will be click on the
apply button we will call them just
clicks too short to shorten up a bit so
knowing how many of these you will have
is very useful because first of all you
have a client and he expects something
so
if you know beforehand what he might
actually expect it goes a long way in
building a stable relationship whereas
if you if you don't know then you might
promise him something that you will not
be able to deliver and secondly once you
actually know what entices people to hit
that apply button you can try to suggest
them some improvements right you can
maybe move the text a little bit maybe
add a picture or two or maybe you want
to refresh the offer once a few days
have passed so all these things are
things that we could suggest based on
our data and if they provide the
employers with more clicks then we get
more business basically but model is not
enough I mean just knowing what will
happen does not bring you anything you
need to somehow extract the business
value of that knowledge and this usually
goes through creating some sort of a
product some sort of a framework it
might be an API where something someone
can automatically for example check
different types of offer write different
types of content to see how it works
or maybe it can just be a web
application for our customer care and
sales teams where they can see how the
offer will rank among its peers and make
suggestions to the employers and
operationalizing such a project creating
a model creating an application is is a
difficult thing and because of that we
would like to share with you our free
stage process to developing products
data science products in an agile way
and these will provide you meaningful
milestones so that you know where you
actually finished one step and you can
go to the other one and this way you can
save lots of time and money and the
three steps are experiment creating
interface and pushing to production and
on the surface it might seem that it's
basically the same
mas normal software engineering projects
right you'll also start with an
experiment and rollout production bla
bla bla
however data science projects have their
set of unique problems and challenges so
for example already starting with the
first stage the experiment when you are
creating when I was working as a as web
developer usually what will happen is
that my product owner would come and
tell me and make this make like
something possible make a use case
possible for them and I would do that
and then he would come with some
feedback and he would iterate back and
forth until finally he was happy with
they the science is not that simple if I
spend one month creating a model for you
and then you come back and tell me you
know what maybe we should like change
this output a little bit then basically
I've wasted a month of my time and I
have to start from scratch so moreover
it the experiment might not even be like
possible to conduct consider this a few
years ago Google promised that they will
predict the number of calories just from
looking at the photo of the meal and
unfortunately they're still struggling
and not every company has the resources
that Google has to keep working on a the
same experiment for three years I for
now know that my product owner would
kill me if I did that so once you know
that your model is more or less capable
of handling the problem you try to
develop an MVP and at this step it's
what I said earlier about the the
knowing the business requirements you
have to pinpoint them exactly you don't
have like the wiggling room to kind of
iterate and come up with ten different
models and ten different apps you have
to first know what we will actually do
and then create an MVP and as for the
last stage pushing the production well
here the challenges are mostly projects
specific I'd say that usually this comes
to data pipelining and integrating
different data sources but as I said
this is like the the this depends on the
total like environment in which you
create the app so the way we will
proceed here is that Magda will go on
the use case that I described earlier
with you through all the stages and how
it panned out in our case and then we'll
pick some and make it may go to
conclusions okay
so we started to create our product from
an experiment which was which was about
to help us to see if users behavior is
predictable enough to get some useful
results of our model one of the most
important things about creating good
data science experiment is to establish
the point in which the experiment will
be found as successful and this point
should be in moment when product owners
assumptions about the accuracy of the
model are fulfilled it is often very
useful to simplify the problem for
example well-known case about predicting
user ratings from from the reviews
instead of guessing exact score they try
to predict if if it will be better or
not from median and we followed similar
pattern and instead of predicting the
whole possible spectrum of clicks on our
offer we try to answer the question
whether this particular offer will be
below or above median of clicks of all
historical offers if you want to build
and train useful model you need
well-prepared data and this is very
important to make sure that you have
everything that you need and all secure
endpoints at the beginning of creating
the product because it may take some
time for example in our case it took
quite a while we decided to build two
separate models one for the features of
the offer like region
etc and the other for the content of the
offer our approach was intended to show
us the usefulness of each element we
chose extra boost for features of the
offer at the beginning and simple neural
network with lsdm for the content of the
offer as we realized later on we
probably should have started with eg
boots with bag of words instead of
neural network because results were
similar and it took significantly less
time to Train both models achieved
accuracy at about 80 percent which was a
satisfying result for a product owner
and we could continue work on this
subject we even tried to combine models
in a simple way by voting classifier
with with soft true soft voting rule
means that we averaged probabilities of
all models and check whether the result
was above 50% since we had only two
models and probabilities for neural
network were rather extreme it usually
overweighted the other model and even
though there was a very low correlation
between probabilities of models it
didn't give us any good result after we
achieved promising results from our
experimental phase we could proceed to
creating product which would answer
business needs and first thing that we
had to do was to clarify business needs
about the target of the model estimating
with respect only to the median was too
general for for our business and we
settled on quarters moreover we
calculated quarters not for all offers
anymore but separately for all
combinations of regions and categories
of offers then we could started to work
on our Minimum Viable Product for
use it and we've built a web application
with Django for our customer care
department it is very important and
sometimes also difficult to deliver data
science work in an easy and
understandable way for users who might
have nothing in common with machine
learning and this challenge comes with
many DevOps and front-end tasks which is
a great opportunity to cooperate with
other teams in your company so guess
what we did almost everything on our own
and probably this was the reason why it
took us about a quarter instead of a
month while you are working in an agile
environment you are expected to deliver
small parts of bigger tasks one after
another but data science style of
working differs a little bit and after
you settle the architecture of the model
you have some time while model is being
trained and you can use this time to do
something else and this is the main
reason why we were able to develop model
and build web application at the same
time in relation to agile to working in
agile environment it is also very
important to document all your work
I mean write down the architecture of
the model the set of parameters that you
have used and the results of this model
and by this you can avoid repeating your
own work or work of your colleagues at
this moment we had data in many
different in many different places and
our and we had really huge stock
technology technology stack but we
decided not to address this at this
moment because we prioritized
development speed over integration you
have to remember also that something can
go wrong always can go wrong
and you may need to go back to the
previous version of your model and of
course versioning code with github is
extremely popular among engineers and
data scientists but if you are a data
scientist you may also need to go to the
previous version of your data set and
this is one thing that we have learned
during this during building this this
model right now we have a server where
we put our data sets in a folder and we
have simple simple bar script which say
which saves these data sets with the
date of modification of them and at this
moment we are running tests with our
users and we are waiting for the next
iteration of their feedback so that we
would be able to implement changes and
improve its business value and after we
finish this part we will be able to move
to the last part of creating our product
which is pushing to production the
moment you are going to transfer your
product into production version is the
best time to look after the quality of
your code maintenance of coat which is
modularized and his unit tests - almost
every function is much easier but it is
also important to separate training of
your model from the application in order
to of course keep the code clean and
transparent but also to reduce costs
very often if you need to train the
model you you need stronger hardware but
for a shorter period of time whereas the
application itself uses very low
computing power but it needs to be
available all the time what are possible
challenges when you move your product to
production version for example like in
our case you can have two databases
which requires completely different
kind of connection and sometimes very
expensive joining data but there can
also be problem problem well difference
between getting training data and
inference data
the former is usually a bad job which
you can do once a week or once a month
whereas the latter needs to be done on
demand and these two types of requests
would completely different strain on a
database one is high volume and low
frequency and the other is the opposite
and what are our plans for future with
our products we are about to integrate
our internal databases with Google cloud
and invest in automation of training the
model and substituting it into
production yes so Magda just went
through a couple of lessons that we've
learned along our way and I believe they
are all very important but just in case
you know it doesn't go down the
generations as the most important PI
data talk ever and studied in school we
thought maybe summarizing would be a
useful thing so we came up with a few
key insights that are that we think
would be most useful for people to
consider when they start their data
science project and they want to do it
in an agile way so starting with data
scientists first of all as Magda said
make sure you know what data you will
use getting this data then can take a
lot of time and be a serious bottleneck
if you start with that then you make
sure that you will get it
when you need it second of all document
all your experiments so when developing
a model you will usually try a variety
of architectures and parameters and
often times you will develop some you
will choose some model
but then have to come back a few months
later so documenting what data you used
what was the architecture what were that
the parameters and what were the
conclusions goes a long way in not only
preserving the knowledge and making sure
you don't repeat yourself but it's also
a useful tool in transferring knowledge
between among the data scientists and
thirdly something that Magda also talked
about was making sure that you know
which data corresponding to which
version of your application so this kind
of knowing where your data came from is
called data provenance and it will again
save you time when you implement it and
you will be able to come back when
something goes wrong and in real life
things always go wrong and moving to
product owners imagine there is nothing
there's not many of them but just put
yourself in their shoes first of all you
need to know your goals if you don't
know what you're actually what accuracy
you're striving for and what metric what
level of the metric the new risk one
that your data scientist will keep
playing with a data set for a year
because just because they like it or
secondly you might end up working three
years on a problem that you're simply
unable to solve with the data that you
have
so this knowing what you aim for is
something that can both save you time
and money
secondly from experience I know if you
tell me to make a model I will
immediately think of you know going to
the one that I most like or is most
exciting and usually it's also the more
complex one in reality in business
applications usually you want to start
low check with linear regression works
check with SVM's
if FTMs work check your gradient
boosting works and then maybe you can
move
to something harder as a rule of thumb
if your data scientist asks you tells
you that he needs that he totally needs
to implement this neural network to
solve the problem look them in the eye
and ask no but do you really do and
thirdly although Magda is certainly the
best front-end developer in group abroad
suey let's just go with this you might
sometimes need help from DevOps from
front-end developers from machine
learning Engineers make sure that your
team has access to them and that they
can focus on the most important parts of
their job and that's basically
everything we might be preparing a more
advanced version of the stock so if
you'd like to know something about
optimizing the usage of CPU or data in
practice or some other topic related to
agile please let us know also we have
business cards we had to tell
administration that business cards are
very important so don't make us look
like fools and come get a few and yeah
that's it
thank you okay before the first question
you can do a more advanced version of
this of stock on the on our Meetup just
let us know where a couple of meetup
land is here so yeah the question my
question is about more down-to-earth
aspects of agile management could you
please comment how do you what are your
experience with such things as daily
scrums
or daily meetups and stand-ups sorry
daily stand-ups or back logging in terms
of more less iterative job as developing
data science projects sure so in our
case we're not doing daily stand-ups
when we did they were very technical and
they were not really
useful for the product owner so what we
usually do is we have like our own
meetings only the three of us data
scientists where we discuss our work and
we communicate we we invite the product
owner or the scrum master if if they're
needed and as for planning yes I'd say
it's very challenging we overestimate
the amount of time that things will take
or underestimate a lot of times usually
underestimation because we're ambitious
yeah I also think that agile like the
down-to-earth side to agile is more
challenging in data science just because
you don't really you never know what
will be the next stage but I still think
it's useful because it kind of provides
first of all it provides a framework
where you can actually see where you are
in relation to your goals and second of
all it's a great way to keep your
product owner in touch with what you're
actually doing thank you one more
a great duck sorry if I didn't catch
that but you said that you're working in
scrum on Ajo
right but it requires two weeks for
example sprints and you have to define
what you will deliver after these two
weeks so the question is how that
definition is defined how do you find
what you're going to do like what's
going to be done but by this date
like for example product owner wants
let's say 90 percent of accuracy on
something and probably you cannot say
that will have that accuracy in two
weeks because it's not possible you have
to experiment right so what are the
definitions have done let's say after
the two-week spring usually in our case
we we don't define by accuracies because
as you say that would be silly and we
can't expect that our model will improve
by this and that more likely we would
for example say in these two weeks we
will try to develop the model for
example in our case they will remember
there were two models there was model
based on the content of the offer the
words that are in there and one based on
the kind of like specification of the
offer what's the region and so on so we
would say okay these two weeks we're
working on this model and after that we
come back to our product owner we tell
him what was the accuracy that we were
able to do and he makes a decision based
on a few things first of all based on
how whether or not it actually meets his
criteria right but second of all he
would usually ask us if how much time
would it would it take for our next step
of improving the model so for example we
would say okay we couldn't we can spend
some more time tuning parameters or we
can spend some more time developing
different kinds of models or in samples
so this I can already estimate right and
that's what I would would tell him okay
I think we can leave the rest of the
comments and questions too
after talk discussions so probably gonna
find Yannick manga someone here - yeah
at lunch
because everyone was running to lunch
okay so I don't want to keep you here
we're meeting at free
[Applause]
you